peter because i am always very very uh
hospitable to uh my co-hosts i'm gonna
let you have the first pick in today's
show me something draft for week two
all right here's who i wanna see
something from here's who's got to show
me something in week two and that's
jimmy garoppolo
now look you might say well gee that's
kind of unfair his three biggest weapons
all of them are either not gonna play or
will be hobbled george kittle devo
samuel brandon iok
so
is it really fair and the answer is yes
it is fair
because you're playing at the new york
football jets
okay and you're not only playing at the
jets
who you should beat regardless
but
this is a case where if you're a great
quarterback in the nfl you are going to
have sundays
when your team is depleted around you
and you
have to win the game so jimmy garoppolo
this is your life sunday at the jets i
want to see something from you
yeah look i agree with that the injuries
around a quarterback aren't an excuse
when you're one of the highest paid
quarterbacks in the game now he's not
one of the highest paid anymore he's
been leapfrogged multiple times over but
when he got his contract 27.5 million a
year was the highest paid quarterback in
all of football
so
you're expected to go out there and make
it work with what you have we've seen
other great quarterbacks make it work
with what they have and they still have
a running game that is potent jordan
reed was was more than competent last
week in the passing game up so i i think
it's fair to expect jimmy garoppolo to
play better deliver the pass accurately
if the guy drops it it's on him but
there were a lot of occasions last week
where garoppolo wasn't accurate he threw
the hospital ball that got george kittle
injured a wildly overthrown screen pass
attempts so garoppolo deserves a
criticism and you're right we need to
see more from him all right next one
from me and this one is co-authored by
tiki barber saquon barkley show me
something some harsh criticism from tiki
barber this week saying that
saquon barkley shouldn't be in every
down back because he doesn't want to hit
anybody in pass protection barkley said
i don't look at that as disrespect i'm
going to look at it as a challenge well
the real challenge is to get more than
10 yards on 15 carries he was only the
sixth guy since the merger to be held
under 10 yards with 15 or more carries
this is one of the best running backs in
football i know the offensive line isn't
great but there have been plenty of
great running backs who still get their
yards without great offensive lines so
saquon barkley needs to step up if the
giants are gonna have a chance to beat
the bears peter
uh no question about it i am gonna go
on the other team in that game and we
talked about him earlier
but
you know mitchell trubisky's got to show
me something this week okay he's coming
off
the
in some ways even though he had the
magic season you know and the bears had
the magic season
there was so much on him in week one you
know not playing well having beaten out
nick foles for the job he comes into the
fourth quarter first three touchdown
passes
and basically if they could have carried
them off the field on their shoulders
they would have
but now we come into okay what have you
done for me lately and can we play a
complete game now please
and you're playing a team that when you
look at the schedule
if you're gonna make anything of your
season you play the new york giants at
home
you have to win that game and to me
i think when you look at mitchell
trubisky he's got to put a complete game
together against the new york giants and
win that game this is a game that if the
bears are going to make anything of
their season they've got to have and
i've got to see it for four quarters not
just one out of mitchell trubisky
hey same concept in tampa bay if the
buccaneers are going to make out of
their season what we expect them to make
out of their season they've got to beat
the panthers and tom brady has got to
show us something otherwise he's going
to get called out again by his head
coach but this is a game that's set up
for tom brady to perform better than he
did week one yes they got the short
straw right out of the gates toughest
game on the schedule as you said earlier
in the show peter going to new orleans
to play the saints that's just how it
works sometimes now you got to take a
game that you should win and go out and
take care of business and tom brady has
to play like the tom brady that we
thought he was going to be
and that we still think he can be even
though he's 43 years old if he doesn't
do it this week i don't know when he's
going to do it so uh you know the the
the ultimate 180 from the toughest game
on the schedule to arguably the easiest
game on the schedule he's got to take
care of business on sunday or it really
is panic time for the buccaneers
yeah i totally agree mike and i think he
will i think he's gonna play well
um and i think just as tom brady is
learning his receivers
i think now bruce arians and byron
leftwich can go into the laboratory you
know monday all day
looking at their game plan looking at
what they did well in new orleans and
what they didn't do well
and they can figure out okay i mean one
of the things that carson palmer always
told me about uh about bruce arians he
said i've never had a coach in my career
who knows what i can do in this
particular week against this off against
this defense better than bruce arians
you know he's a master of creating a
plan every week based on how you can
attack that defense so i think that's
the way they're going to handle it but i
agree mike this is a game where all eyes
are going to be on tom brady
i'm going to make a second i'm going to
make my third pick and it's going to be
a little bit of an upset special but i'm
going to choose and keel harry of the
new england patriots because we all know
right now that look
whether the patriots win this division
or not the only way that they're going
to be a threat to do anything in the
playoffs this year
is if they get some alternatives in the
passing game that they currently do not
have
harry had a shaky game the other day cam
newton came out was his biggest
cheerleader this week in his press
conference
all things are there all the support is
there
for in keele harry to become a big
player in the new england defense or in
the new england offense and to me
this is the week at seattle when you
don't want to rely on cam newton running
it 15 times a game
you need to have a guy
come through in the passing game whose
name isn't julian edelman
yeah i agree with you completely they
need that because at some point the
run's not going to be there and the
receivers need to step up all right
somebody who needs to step up and this
one's easy for me because he said so
himself he can't be upset about this
it's vikings defensive end yannick and
gawkway he wanted out of jacksonville he
got out of jacksonville he took less
money to go to a place he wanted to go
and that's where he is and he said
yesterday i've still got a bad taste in
my mouth from week one i want to make it
right this weekend right now this
defensive line in this defense needs a
spark and i need to go make this spark
this weekend he's got six and a half
career sacks in eight games against the
colts he knows that team well this is
the time for ngakway to make the vikings
look smart for giving up a second round
pick and a fifth round pick that could
become a third round pick in 2022 and 12
million dollars for a guy who no longer
was going to play for the jaguars well
he's already got something in common in
minnesota with what he had in jaguar in
jacksonville they lost and they're going
to lose again if they don't get some
semblance of a pass rush this weekend
peter
and the other part of this is mike you
know yannick and gawkway came in to be a
bookend okay in which everybody wants to
have somebody on the other side that
teams are going to pay attention to
and last year he had the developing josh
allen uh on the other side and he had
calais campbell on the other side so you
know now you're looking at yannick and
gawkway and where is the other huge pass
rusher with denial hunter out there
isn't one so there's going to be more
focus on him he's probably going to have
to fight through more attention more
chip blocks than he would normally and
this is a game where
if he is a great player this is where
great players have to come in
and really lead their team but i i i
think in gawkway is a great pick
yeah and we'll see what the vikings can
do they have to avoid falling to oh and
on sunday night though that's the game
of the week two teams at 1-0 the
seahawks and the patriots peter that's
the one i'm looking forward to i mean
all is right in the world when that
sunday night game is the one that stands
out as the game that you must see and to
have cam newton and russell wilson
getting together i i i it's a shame it's
happening so early in the season but i'm
not complaining i'll take it for week
two i'll take it whenever i can get it
russell wilson and cam newton
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports